Harvard University history and Business
Administration Professor Neil Ferguson
talks about the life and influence of
financier Sigmund Warburg whose
london-based bank SG Warburg played an
important role in rebuilding post-world
War two Europe the New York Historical
Society in New York City hosts the
50-minute talk well thank you very much
indeed deal thank you ladies and
gentlemen for coming tonight it's a
great pleasure to be with you in what
turns out to be an extraordinarily
appropriate venue now you may not
associate bankers with ethical culture
but what I proposed to do this evening
is to introduce you to a banker who was
steeped in ethical culture and who I
feel would have got on very well with
Felix Adler also a German born Jew who
of course called this society into being
I want to begin by asking a very
fundamental question and that relates to
how many of you know who's Sigmund
Warburg was my guess is that it's only a
minority of you who had heard of him
before this evening his name is much
better known in London where indeed he
spent most of his financial career but
that's not really a sufficient
explanation for the relative obscurity
in New York of a man who was without
question one of the towering figures of
post-war world finance
I think the key has to do with our
neglect of bankers as a fit subject for
biography
why write the biography of a banker as a
purpose say to a dictator or perhaps a
great Democratic leader a prime minister
or a president why write the biography
of a banker when you could be writing
the biography of a king or a princess or
an actress in order to show you how we
attach importance to different kinds of
historical figure I want to show you
some statistics if you go as I did
recently to the British library's
general reference collection catalog and
simply find out how many books have been
written about these different people you
will be rather startled by the result
Hitler is the clear winner 478 books
appear in that catalog about adult
Hitler pipping Stalin to the post for
most storied dictator
Mussolini comes in with the bronze medal
edging out Mao Winston Churchill I'm
afraid beats your own Abraham Lincoln
but don't feel bad because Churchill was
of course half American Henry the eighth
is the most written about royal he has
19 books about him a Diana Princess of
Wales is quite a distant second on 39
notice that that's only one more than
Marilyn Monroe but when we get to
bankers it's as if the biographers
suddenly leave the library in
embarrassment there are two or maybe
three books about sequin war book three
if you count Ron churners a book about
the entire Warburg family a two if you
only count my book
and Jacque at Ali's biography of Warburg
an unusual book Jacques Attali
incidentally was for many years Francois
Mitterrand close confidant
it's an unusual book because it's a
biography exclusively based as far as I
can tell on the imagination
my book is based on reading my way
through about 10,000 letters and diary
entries and memoranda which Warburg kept
in the course of his life
unlike many finances I should explain
Warburg was a remarkably prolific writer
and that for a biographer is a huge
advantage now I don't really know quite
why you would need to ask the question
why bankers when you reflect on the
events of the last three years it should
be obvious that bankers are historically
important and I would go so far as to
say more important than actresses
perhaps even more important than
princesses for if anything has shaped
our lives in the last three years it's
been a financial crisis which many
people are inclined to blame entirely on
bankers now I'm not one of those people
who thinks that bankers are solely
responsible for a crisis that clearly
was caused by a whole coalition of
negligent groups regulators rating
agencies not forgetting the politicians
who did so much to stoke the real estate
bubble but still you would have a
difficult job I think you'll agree
writing the history of the last decade
and leaving out Goldman Sachs
I'll take the Oldman as an example but
it's just an example I could equally
well have taken any of the major
financial institutions that have played
such a dominant role in modern economic
history it has to be historically
significant that on the eve of the
crisis the chief executive of Goldman
Sachs was being paid 2,000 times the
average income in this country it has to
be significant that a bank had net
revenues greater than the gross domestic
product of more than a hundred countries
and it has to be
significant that that institution at a
time of financial crisis not only
converted itself into a bank holding
company from an investment bank but also
secured indirectly a bailout via the
bailout of AIG at a time when the
Treasury secretary was the former chief
executive officer of that Bank call me
cranky but I just think that's
historically important for some reason
Lloyd Blankfein's picture had
disappeared from that last slide I
showed you which makes me feel slightly
uneasy I wonder what else has been
removed and by whom what when logged
Blankfein was challenged by the Sunday
Times in the now-famous interview last
year he replied ironically I think that
he was just doing God's work but public
reaction certainly in Britain was not I
think to detect the irony and the fact
that the bank then had to settle with
the SEC for some 550 million dollars to
settle fraud charges tells you something
very important about about our times
about the bankers when Rolling Stone
magazine called Goldman Sachs the great
vampire squid I think that was a
historically significant moment I think
that's a quotation that will appear in
the history books another one that ought
to appear is John Mac's famous
declaration which I heard to make him
aided in New York we cannot control
ourselves you have to step in and
control the street I was stunned when I
heard him say that though I suppose in
some ways it was better than claiming to
be doing God's work
the collapse of public confidence the
public trust in bankers is one of the
most striking features of our time if
you look at opinion data bankers are now
less trusted by the public than
journalists and that takes some doing
I'm a historian that's why I'm so
engaged with and committed to the New
York Historical Society what historians
are best at doing is taking documents
the things that people leave behind and
making historical sense of them before I
talk at all about Sigmund Warburg I want
to juxtapose his ethos the financial
ethos of his generation with the ethos
of the present generation and there is
no document that does this better in my
view than the email correspondence of
fab fab piece tour goldman sachs trader
and uber mensch
these emails which were written to a
quite large number of different
girlfriends
he was diversified in that respect as in
so many others are I think a better
summation of the spirit of our age than
any other document you could possibly
find in order to grasp the full charm of
these documents it's necessary to read
them in a French accent more and more
leverage in this system the entire
edifice threatened to collapse at any
moment only potential survivor the
fabulous fab standing in the middle of
all these complex highly levered exotic
trade he creates without necessarily
understanding of the implications of
these monstrosities anyway not feeling
too guilty about this the real purpose
of my job is to make capital markets
more efficient and ultimately provides
the US consumer with more efficient ways
to leverage himself so there is a humble
noble and ethical reason for my job
amazing our Buddha arm in convincing
myself
let me take you back to a lost world the
lost world that produced Simon Warburg
who grew up in the early 20th century in
South Germany he was part of a
distinguished banking dynasty the
Varberg had established themselves
successfully in Hamburg in the 19th
century and had by the late 19th century
almost emerged from the shadow of the
Rothschilds the dominant Jewish banking
dynasty of the 19th century but Sigmund
wasn't part of that Hamburg scene his
father was a sickly idiosyncratic member
of of the dynasty who would probably
have been regarded as Meshuga at that
time there he is with the young Sigmund
and sigmaz mother Lucy in the first
picture and because he was so clearly
unsuited to the financial cut and thrust
he was sent to a kind of genteel exile
in South Germany in the Swabian
countryside that's where sequin grew up
and an altogether different ambience
atmosphere from his relatives in Hamburg
from almost the first moment he could he
read he was a voracious reader and I am
here above all else to celebrate the
book as a vehicle for the communication
of culture and ethical culture he
married and flourished he flourished not
only as a banker he hadn't really wanted
to be a banker he had literary and
academic and even political ambitions
but circumstances obliged him to enter
the family business
his father's savings were wiped out by
the post First World War hyperinflation
of 1923 and his ambitions in Hamburg
were dealt a lethal blow when the family
bank of mm varberg more or less went
bust in the great banking crisis
of 1930-31 and then after that his hopes
of any life in Germany at all were
dashed by the advent of the National
Socialist regime in 1933 and the
subsequent so-called Aryan ization of
the of the Varberg family bank it's a
sequence life course like the life
course of so many people in the mid 20th
century was fundamentally altered by
inflation depression and totalitarianism
and he had to start over almost from
scratch because it was so very hard for
somebody of his religion leaving Germany
to take money with him so my story is a
story of somebody who had to start over
and he chose to start over in London it
might very well have been New York but
his wise Swedish father-in-law man named
philipson gave him an outstanding advice
he saw that Warburg skills would be more
salient would have more impact in the
stuffier club ear somewhat more
sclerotic atmosphere of London maybe the
truth is if Sigmund had come to New York
there would have been more sequence to
compete with in London as I will show
you he cut an extraordinary almost
unique figure in the post-war period the
New York side of the story is
fascinating some of you will be familiar
with it through his uncles Paul and
Felix Sigmund Warburg was related to the
Schiff family and therefore had a direct
interest in that extraordinary cousin
who that dominated Manhattan and
particularly the financial world of the
early 20th century the firm of Kuhn Loeb
& Company has vanished
Don the way of all flesh along with more
recent casualties like
Lehman Brothers but Kuhn Loeb was once a
name to conjure with in this city it was
in fact the name on a par with JP Morgan
in the days when Jacob Schiff there the
great patriarch at the center of the
family group was the master of railroad
finance in this city so for those of you
who are dedicated to the study of New
York history and New York history alone
this book has something for you what it
has is a tale of of failure Sigmund
Warburg's failure to persuade his ship
relatives and particularly John Schiff
one of the children in that photograph
at the bottom that he had to change Kuhn
Loeb or it would die
it's an extraordinary drama a
transatlantic drama Warburg became a
director of Kuhn Loeb spent weeks and
months in New York trying to turn the
firm around and ultimately failed was
ultimately forted by his own relatives
the rest if you want to follow that
story is in the book so the scene after
the failure to turn Kuhn Loeb around
shifts to London and it's a tale of
resurrection resurrection of the City of
London as a financial center my argument
is that nobody contributed more to the
revival of London as the world's great
international financial center than
Sigmund Warburg in a whole series of
innovations
he turned London around and to grasp the
magnitude of his achievement you need to
recognize that in 1945 London was pretty
much finished or seemed finished as a
financial center a bankrupt country with
a socialist government capital controls
exchange controls rationing of
everything hardly seemed like a place
that would rise to rival New York in the
post-war period that he did owes much to
Warburg
Simon Warburg made a distinction which
will be familiar to many of you between
two kinds of banking transactions
banking and relationship banking and the
interesting thing is that in his mind
transactions banking was an earlier
model that could be blamed for the
depression and relationship banking from
the vantage point of the 1950s was the
future we often tend to think of it as
the other way round relationship banking
was something slightly old-fashioned and
fuddy-duddy that was swept away in the
heroic days of the 1980s and 1990s
viewed from the vantage point of
Warburg's generation this is the wrong
way to think of it viewed from that
vantage point we reran the experiment
with transaction banking with the same
result
if financial institutions are dominated
by volume transactions piling them high
and selling them cheap or more likely
selling them dear if relationships with
clients are replaced purely by
transactions with counterparties don't
be surprised if you come close to
another great depression the distinction
sets out very clearly here in one of
them brought Warburg's memoranda on the
subject transactions banking was just
about channeling money relationship
banking was about changing and adjusting
management and capital structures of
industrial and financial businesses to
alterations in our environments to him
that was the true purpose of banking
personally he wrote in 1964 I'm not
interested in the waves of despondency
in enthusiasm these are appropriate for
people who look upon matters purely from
a stock exchange point of view however
if we want to succeed meaning the bank
that took his name after the war SG
Warburg & Company we must make up our
mind to follow a policy of establishing
new values and new procedures rather
than to act mainly as traders and
sellers of securities which we find
relatively easy to dispose of in other
words we must be aware that we are
primarily
and only secondarily stock exchange
traders one way of understanding the
history of our time ladies and gentlemen
is that the traders took over from the
bankers with results we all now know
well let me briefly tell you what this
Bank did it was a small firm by modern
standards small in terms of the capital
small in terms of the number of
employees small because Warburg believed
that small was beautiful and that
financial institutions should not be too
large it was a bank that did a lot of
fee-based corporate finance mergers and
acquisitions he pioneered the hostile
takeover as an art form in post-war
London it was an asset management firm
though he'd rather disapproved of that
side of the business the euro bond
market which was enormously vital market
for harnessing the accumulated dollars
in the continent and elsewhere putting
them to work was in large measure his
bank's invention he also pioneered an
entirely different way of managing a
bank
internally banks in his early years were
more like gentlemen's clubs the partners
sat in oak-paneled rooms and the clerks
were in a different floor and never ever
had anything to do with the partners the
major senior employees would turn up at
about 10:00 a.m. have the first free
dinner a pre lunch drink at about 12:00
and be thinking about the golf course by
about four Warburg changed all that open
plan offices an egalitarian structure in
which all directors no matter how senior
or junior had equal voice it changed the
culture of banking he made them start
work early so this is an extraordinary
story of innovation financial innovation
of what I which I think was of a
positive nature one fee which we earned
from giving good service to one of our
large industrial clients can be far in
excess of what we earn in a whole year
in connection with euro bond issues for
war
relationships with corporate clients
were the key it was a profitable Bank
this chart shows you real net profits
adjusted for inflation and you can see
what extraordinarily buoyant years the
50s and 60s were and what a struggle the
seventies were you can also see that the
share price tracks that performance
pretty much exactly it was a great thing
to buy a share in the parent company
mercury securities in the 50s or early
60s it was rather tougher to hang on to
it during the 1970s when double-digit
inflation cost so much trouble to the UK
economy but ladies and gentlemen it's
not the performance of the bank I want
to focus on because that's not what
sequin Warburg focused on I was very
puzzled when I was writing this book
because as I read through Sigmund
Warburg's letters and diaries and
memoranda I couldn't find any references
at all to the bottom line
in fact he hardly ever talked about
money sums things profits cash flow it's
not there and for about three years I
couldn't write the book I was paralyzed
how could I write a book about a banker
who didn't appear to care about money
who on earth would want to read that
then slowly as I suspect only comes from
immersion and documentary sources I
began to get it and they had to see that
for Warburg the bottom line was not the
most important thing it was something
that would take care of itself if you
did things right in a wonderful
memorandum to John Schiff in 1953
Sigmund Warburg set out what he called
the important elements of a first class
private banking business these were the
five-foot bonk principal hoods bonk was
a phrase he loved and that's why the
book is called high financier number one
moral standing number two reputation for
efficiency and high-quality brain work
number three connections number four
capital funds number five personnel and
organization all those five I think it
is fair to say that most institutions in
the financial world over the past twenty
or so years dropped number one and
number four by the time they were done
all they were left with was the
connections I want to talk about each of
these in turn
but the most important by far was moral
standing can you imagine any of today's
financial geniuses putting moral
standing first is moral standing a
phrase that fab 2 would use in emails to
his many girlfriends I think not the
basic conception of our firm has always
been founded on the following principle
success success from the financial and
from the prestige point of view
important and self understood as it is
is not enough what matters even more is
constructive achieved when added here
ins to high moral and aesthetic
standards in the way in which we do our
work for me that was the moment the
moment I suddenly got it
yes of course the bottom line is
important but you don't really need to
think about it all the time it's a
necessary byproduct of adherence to high
moral and aesthetic standards high
quality work I don't want you to get the
idea that I'm delivering a sermon and
that this book is some kind of austere
moral code for future bankers it is also
fun it's fun because Warburg's was a fun
place to work fun although it was hard
work and sometimes terrifying work
because of this kind of thing Peter
Storm at darling was a relatively junior
director one day he was at home when the
phone rang
and it was his boss I do hope I'm not
disturbing you I don't know mr. Warburg
not at all
well it's about your note the dated 22nd
December on the American stock market do
you have a copy in front of you ah
no kind of red mud cookies in the office
let me remind you of your second
sentence in the fifth paragraph I think
there should be a comma after the word
development now this is in itself
characteristic bit of Warburg pedantry
but what makes this story significant is
that this happened on Christmas Day
perfectionism an obsession with
precision grammar and syntax and
spelling and punctuation was one of the
trademarks of SG Warburg and that seems
to me to be an important point about
this man his belief that if one pursued
perfection even aesthetic perfection in
the letters you wrote to the Bank of
England then the bank would be bound to
succeed the pursuit of perfection seems
to me to be one of the keys to
understanding his personality
point number three connections most of
the substantial transactions which have
been done by so the result of the
cultivation of contacts over very many
years it is of course important that the
technical details of a transaction are
dealt with in the most thorough and
painstaking manner possible
but this should not make us forget that
this would be fruitless without human
contact with the client in question in
our kind of business the continuity of
valuable connections overrides an
importance the conclusion of any
specific transactions and there you have
it the essence of the difference between
a transactions based model and a
relationships based model
it's that conservation of relationships
which Warburg saw as central to the
activity of a banker in fact he
frequently compared himself to a
physician to a doctor and would describe
his relationship to corporate clients as
like the relations
between the doctor and a patient I am
NOT impressed by profits earned at
business which carried undue liquidity
risks memo - dick fooled the entire
financial system in 2006-7 was taking
massive risks in terms of liquidity and
hardly anybody noticed when you look at
the balance sheets of the firm's that
blew up in 2008 they were so leveraged
and so reliant on short-term financing
you can hardly believe they did it so
I'm taking you back in this book to a
time when anchors really worried about
liquidity here's another example of
Warburg fun it is always wrong to look
at the bright side of the picture I can
relate to that as a Scotsman completely
one always risks being tempted into
complacency not you of course but some
of our colleagues if they see that for
the last 25 years our non-recurring
profits of each year occurred on an
ever-growing scale may end up
considering this as a normal state of
affairs now that wasn't actually Warburg
that was one of the other German refugee
directors Charles Sharpe carve Spitz as
he was originally known who used to
write sketches making fun of the Warburg
culture every now and then the mood
would take him and he would write his
wonderful satirical comedies in which
the foibles of the firm's chief would be
satirized how many firms in the
financial world today produce quality
satire in-house
and the way in which it was organized
the way this bank was run it's a
fantastically interesting combination of
the culture of the Jewish refugees not
only Warburg but his partner Henry Grimm
felt and the others who'd come in the
1930s and on the other side the culture
of the public school boys that they
recruited from Winchester from Eton and
the rest the public school buyers
treated the German and Austrian refugees
like the house masters at a particularly
eccentric public school and so the
Monday morning meeting that they all had
to attend was referred to as morning
prayers this culture I think was a
highly creative and in many ways
appealing one it was a culture that
valued above all brains but also the
written word there was an extraordinary
esperen sea of communication at war
books all the ingoing and outgoing
correspondence was pulled everybody
could have read it and everybody was
expected to read it
there was little reliance on the
telephone if the telephone was used a
memorandum had to be written and they
had a rule of four in which any
transaction had to be signed off by four
directors of the company all of this is
to me fascinating and more important
than let us say the sex life of Marilyn
Monroe it's important in two ways it's
important because it tells us how the
financial world changed in the
transition from the culture that had
proved produced the depression to the
culture that produced the glory years of
the post-war economy and it's important
also because it tells us what we're lost
in the generation after Warburg and his
contemporaries faded from the scene he
died in 1982 I calculated that the
average duration of the career of a
chief executive of a major American Bank
in 2007 on the eve of the crisis was 25
years they have basically all come in to
the financial world the year that sea
when Warburg died where did it come from
where did that sense of an ethical
framework come from what can we do to
produce that kind of framework in the
next generation of finances partly it
came from experienced ladies and
gentlemen if you have lived through
hyperinflation depression and the rise
of Hitler you would probably be quite
risk-averse but it wasn't just that it
was also the way he was brought up to me
the most moving document that I read
when I was writing this book was a
document in which Warburg remembered
what his mother had said to him on the
eve of his Bar Mitzvah I want to quote
it to you and I want you to memorize it
and I want you to say it to your
children and your grandchildren from now
on my dear boy you must pray alone in
the evening and you must always ask
yourself before you pray what mistakes
you have made during the preceding day
or what you could have done better if a
whole number of mistakes or omissions do
not at once occur to you then you must
look deeper into yourself until you have
attained the necessary self-knowledge we
all make many mistakes every day and the
most important thing is to be critical
of your own mistakes in the most
unsparing way that is the only way to
arrive at honest prayer Simon Warburg
grew up believing that you should always
cry over spilt milk and you should
always cross bridges before you came to
them I think that's because of his
mother and perhaps if today's bankers
had had mothers like Lucy
Warburg we might not be in quite that
economic mess that we're in now with
that I'm going to thank you for your
attention and invite you to ask me
difficult questions
the rules of the game are as follows
someone other than me will choose who
asks the questions you just have to
raise your hands if you are chosen a
microphone will magically appear in your
hand when the microphone appears in your
hand please stand up so that c-span and
a waiting nation can see who you are
and then when you begin to speak
remember the object of the exercise is
to ask a question not to make a speech
or give a lecture that's me
I do that so questions please question
what was his effects on his children I I
learnt a lot from writing this book over
12 years as a father and one of the
things I learned which is very important
is that when you have a son you have not
cloned yourself many men make the
mistake of thinking that their son
particularly their firstborn son is a
clone and they expect that some to be
the same as them and I think Sigmund War
would make that made that mistake I
don't say that he wasn't a loving father
but his expectations of his son George I
think ultimately were not realistic and
didn't take account of his son's
character and temperament and at the
heart of the book there is I think but a
tragic relationship that would be much
too strong but a painful and fascinating
study in how a father-son relationship
can be can be undermined by unrealistic
expectations and a failure to make the
imaginative leap the imaginative leap
that recognizes your son as someone
quite different so when I began this
book before I had really done the
research
I know I put too much pressure on my son
about homework particularly history
homework and I remember reading some of
the letters between Sigmund and George
and thinking I'm going to make exactly
the same mistake if I'm not careful so
now I think he was a very good son in
many ways the perfect son but as a
father I think he asked too much or
maybe just asked the wrong things his
daughter Anna I think had an altogether
better deal perhaps because she was more
like him but also because she was a
daughter and therefore not expected to
be a clone
in answering that question I hope I've
made it clear that even if you're not
terribly interested in finance at all
and don't care what a Eurobond is this
is a book full of human drama the drama
of exile the drama that comes when you
lose your homeland and the culture which
you feel so closely bound up with and
also the drama that I suppose every
family has going on within it thanks
very much
another question please well I think
calling it a blueprint for today's
bankers would be putting it a bit
strongly the world has changed in many
ways and continues relentlessly to
change in ways that are I think in many
respects disturbing the fact that the
bulk of trades on the New York Stock
Exchange today are executed by
algorithms in microseconds
should worry us the degree to which the
transactions model has somehow triumphed
despite the crisis should trouble us the
degree to which it's hard today to set
up a new bank should trouble us it's
hard because if you were sequin Warburg
today and after all he started his bank
after a depression you would find the
odds were stacked against you by the
too-big-to-fail institutions that enjoy
all kinds of open and not sir open
subsidies from government so a
blueprints probably
not realistic but what I do feel very
passionately about is that when we
consider business education and I am
half of my time at Harvard a professor
at the Business School we should be
making our students more aware of
financial history history has been a
neglected part of business education for
spotting long but also we should make
them aware of the ethical framework that
any businessman needs to operate within
it is not to be just a Bernie Madoff who
didn't get found out so it's not a
blueprint but I hope that it is
something that people will read and take
to heart if it makes some of its readers
uncomfortable if it makes them aware of
what was absent from their
decision-making process before then good
whether they'll read it I don't know
maybe a one page executive summary would
be a good idea but I hope that if not a
blueprint at least it will serve as a
reminder that the finance wasn't always
a moral you know there is a danger in a
crisis like this that we we swing to the
opposite extreme we conclude that that
all bankers are crooks and all banks are
untrustworthy that the crisis was
entirely the fault of these people and
they all belong in jail and that's as
absurd as to believe that markets are
always efficient and also the best in
the best of all possible stock markets
which was our previous pre-crisis error
no I think it's very important to
recognize the volume of the financial
institutions that we have one of the
things I try to argue in the ascent of
money was that finance has been an
integral part of human progress that
financial innovation on balance has been
for good and not for evil and writing
Warburg was a chance to kind of zoom in
and make that same point in in microcosm
because I think he personifies the kind
of finance that has been a real and
lasting benefit to mankind yes
please written a biography of Francis
shades who as you know was affiliated
with the Warburg Institute for many
years and until I have the pleasure of
reading your book I have a couple of
quick questions where our Sigmund's
papers house just what ledger to him
what was his relationship with Abby
Weber
I'm always impressed when someone can
pack four questions into one though I
must tell you madam that I once was
asked a question by a German who managed
to get nine in that's the record
Warburg's papers are in London it's
likely they're not certain that they'll
leave the patent garden archived where
they're currently held and will go to a
university collection in the UK I tried
and failed to get them to the Morgan
Library at the Harvard Business School
the reason I wrote the book was that
after my Rothschild book was published I
wrote a history of the Rothschild Bank
some of Warburg's former colleagues
approached me with the idea that I might
write a biography and at first I was
rather reluctant but when I sat down and
read his diary of 1933 I was absolutely
thunderstruck if you want to get a sense
of how intensely confusing it was to be
a young brilliant ambitious german jew
in 1933 just read the quotations in my
book from from his diary that was what
persuaded me I should I should write the
book the abbe Varberg connection was not
as close as the connection with Abbey's
younger brother Paul
the five brothers for those of you who
don't know the Warburg story were like a
kind of rerun of the five sons of Mayer
Amschel Rothschild except that they they
didn't all go into finance because they
had wider opportunities in the late 19th
century and eBay was the one who was
least suited to finance and most
intensely academic and as you know but
others may not know his more financially
savvy brother max made a deal that max
would take over the family bank and he
would provide a be with their lifetime
supply of all the books he wanted this
open-ended commitment was one of the
worst deals that Max Weinberg ever did
because the
his brother's library is absolutely vast
the library ended up in London and
became the basis for the Warburg
Institute because it obviously had to be
rescued from the clutches of the Nazis
it then became a home for modern art
history anyways the home if you know
anything of art history or another work
of Ernst Gombrich who was for many years
based at the Warburg Institute oh and by
the way if you haven't read Gombrich his
little history of the world do it's a
masterpiece
and I think I've answered all of your
questions no he was not fourth question
he did not have any link to the Warburg
Institute and donated his own library
which is also very large siguen
collected books almost as
enthusiastically as a bee but he donated
his library to st. Paul's girls school
in London where his daughter went four
out of four would every else like to ask
four questions yes sir in the United
States over much of the 20th centuries
after bankers achieved some professional
success they often sought to move more
into public life and influence public
policy at least up until Henry Paulson
and maybe they're going to revisit that
those attempts but I did sigmund ever
harbor any of these ambitions and did he
did he do anything outside of the
banking sphere yes that's a great
question he did in fact he had hoped to
be a politician in the late twenties and
early thirties his plan was to use the
bank as the launching pad for a
political career as a liberal politician
he would have been in the German
Democratic Party the GDP and of course
all of that fell apart for the reasons
we know he never ceased to be
politically engaged he was a passionate
believer in European unity indeed the
Warburg's were among the most important
benefactors a man who's now largely
forgotten can't couldn't have color guy
who was the prophet of pan-european
unity in the twenties and thirties
after the war Sigmund Warburg was
convinced that your
in unity could only brought be brought
about by economic means he felt the
lesson of the 1930s was that nationalism
was too powerful in Europe and so he was
very active in the economic integration
of Europe in one of the chapters in the
book I try to show how institutions like
the euro bond market and cross-border
mergers in business were for Warburg
means to an end
of European unity and although he did
become disillusioned with the way the
European Economic Community turned out
in the 1970s he still believed that that
was a desirable goal perhaps most
interestingly he became a kind of
behind-the-scenes adviser to the Labour
Prime Minister Harold Wilson during the
1960's this is the most from a British
readers point of view extraordinary
revelation of all it's probably a bit
lost on it on a u.s. audience and I
don't want to sound like a provincial
Brit but I Harold Wilson made regular
attacks on bankers and one of his most
famous attacks was when he blamed what
he called the gnomes of Zurich the
gnomes of Zurich is a wonderful phrase
for a sterling crisis in 1967 well while
he was denouncing the gnomes of Zurich
behind the scenes and wholly unknown to
other members of the government he was
dining with Sigmund Warburg who was his
back-channel advisor and I even found a
wonderful occasion when Warburg brought
us a Swiss banker to London to meet
Wilson so that Wilson could see what a
gnome of Zurich was really like
so there was there's a lot of politics
and in the book European politics
British politics and also Cold War
politics two interesting points unlike
some other finances Warburg was
absolutely unrelenting in his hostility
to communism he would do no business
with any communist regime period second
fascinating point in the early 1970s
crisis in the Middle East some of you
will know that a boycott was one weapon
that the Arab League deployed in
addition of course to the oil price hike
the boycott was directed against Jewish
banks and one of the banks singled out
was SG Warburg along with Rothschilds
and others so Warburg found himself in
the very midst of the great
middle-eastern crisis facing the real
possibility of kidnapping even
assassination and I'm fascinated by the
way in which he dealt with that problem
he and his fellow directors weigh
extraordinary quick to phone up and and
harangue any non-jewish bank that
appeared to be appeasing the Arab League
that the most obvious way in which this
happened would be that banks would drop
Warburg's or Rothschilds from the
consortium that were set up for major
bond and stock issues and they were
Warburg was absolutely unforgiving
towards anybody who showed signs of
caving in to that kind of moral
blackmail so there's a lot of politics
in the story and I think that's one
reason that I was I was drawn to it I
suspect I have time for one more
question
Dale what was the relationship of
political contributions in Warburg's
time as it is today we know when AIG was
bailed out land fine Paulson and other
Goldman Sachs people were there and made
sure that our money that was given to
AIG was given to them at a hundred
percent when everyone else didn't get
theirs and if we want to blame the Bush
administration
there is an excellent film which I saw
last night at the New York Film Festival
inside job in which the person who
backed Obama when he ran points out that
none of these people in the Obama
administration have been investigated
for all the fraud they committed and if
one looks at the political contributions
of Goldman and the last election that
went mainly to the Democrats in Obama so
what was the relationship maybe that is
the key question follow the money what
happened to money in politics in
Warburg's time and contrast ours well I
haven't seen at the film that you you
mentioned and it's clear that it will
take financial historians a great deal
of time satisfactorily to unravel the
relationships between the bank's the
politicians congressman and members of
the executive during the financial
crisis we already know from some of the
excellent books like Andrew Ross Sorkin
that the relations were too close for
comfort we also know thanks to the
transparency of the American political
system who gave what to whom to a degree
which is almost unknown in Europe now I
was amazed to find in in 2007/8 when all
this began and I was involved in a
debate on whether Wall Street or
Washington had caused the crisis I was
amazed to find the scale of the
contributions from AIG and other
institutions not least Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac two key figures in Congress
who are of course the authors of the
financial reform bill Barney Frank and
and Christopher Dodd I mean these are
some of the biggest recipients of money
from major financial institutions so go
figure
is this new no no it's not new one of
the points that I tried to make in the
ascent of money is that the nexus
between finance and politics goes all
the way back to the Medici and it
carries all the way through the 18th
century the ED age of John law the 19th
century the age of Nathan and James
Rothschild the 20th century the age of
Morgan and Kuhn Loeb and so forth this
is a problem at the heart of our
capitalist democracy and the biggest
problem of all
is the peril that we oversimplified that
in our frustrations we swing to populist
extremes we say democracy as corrupt and
Jewish finance corrupts it that of
course was precisely the argument that
Hitler made and there were books are
plenty in the late 1920s early 1930s
trying to prove the extent to which
democracy was in thrall to Jewish
finance my role as a historian and this
is the last thing I'm going to say tale
my role as an historian is to focus on
that relationship between finance and
politics between capitalism and
democracy to show its true historical
nature and complexity and to steer a
literate public away from populist
oversimplifications
of the sort that might fuel well let's
say a tea party these days thank you
very much indeed
Neil Ferguson is history and Business
Administration professor at Harvard
Business School his books include
Colossus the rise and fall of the
American Empire and the ascent of money
a financial history of the world for
more information visit neil ferguson
calm this weekend on book TV Alice and
Agnes on weather